je ne suis pas content je me sens content d'avoir du
soleil
dans un sac je suis inutile
il était un caricaturiste et j'étais un
musicien alors nous avons réuni les deux
images et la musique ensemble
j'ai toujours pensé que les deux choses
étaient  en quelque sorte destinés à être ensemble
et quand ils sont faits correctement euh de la bonne
musique et de bonnes images alors c'est vraiment
puissant
nous regardions beaucoup mtv et
euh c'était une époque où il y avait beaucoup de
groupes fabriqués et nous sentions
qu'euh qu'ils  étaient tous de la merde et que
si vous fabriquez quelque chose,
vous devriez pouvoir le faire
correctement, nous avons donc décidé de créer un
groupe de dessins animés
parce qu'il n'y avait pas de groupes de dessins animés
non
et cela nous permettrait de faire des choses
que vous ne pourriez jamais
euh si vous étiez un
groupe physique, vous savez ouais nous pourrions
expérimenter
donc nous avons fait le premier album et beaucoup de
gens n'y croyaient pas
vraiment et nous avons eu beaucoup de
négativité de la part de la presse et
euh vous connaissez des gens dans la musique  l'industrie,
mais ce fut un énorme succès
alors w  nous en avons fait un autre et puis qui
n'était pas encore plus grand donc c'était un
succès encore plus grand et puis nous étions
du côté de tout le monde travaillant avec des
collaborateurs et
faisant des vidéos de dessins animés et
c'était et puis Internet est arrivé et
puis
c'est là où nous en sommes maintenant  nous avions l'habitude d'
aimer le magazine fou
j'aimais euh chuck jones animation
hannah barbera japonais je veux dire je ne sais pas
j'ai grandi dans les années 70 donc il y avait beaucoup
d'animation
nos fantasmes les plus fous dont
robert smith et nelson john certainement
vous savez cocher cette case gorilles et
elton john
et noir ensemble est un mélange inhabituel
mais cela a fonctionné je veux dire si
c'est que tout est possible je pense que je
pense que c'est le point que vous savez
je  Je ne sais pas où ça va, c'est ce qui est
excitant à ce sujet, nous nous sommes rencontrés pour la première fois
quand euh je travaillais pour un magazine
appelé délai oh oui nous l'avons fait et nous avons fait
une interview
avec blair je ne connaissais pas Damon et nous
étions dans un pub
ge  Damon ivre s'est présenté et
m'a immédiatement détesté
et ne voulait pas vraiment me parler en fait,
nous ne nous sommes pas entendus pendant 10 ans à
chaque fois que nous nous sommes vus ouais nous
ne nous aimions pas
beaucoup et il n'était pas moi  Je ne sais pas, nous ne l'avons tout simplement
pas fait,
nous étions comme si nous nous étions beaucoup disputés,
mais nous avons soudainement trouvé des intérêts communs et sommes devenus de
bons amis
depuis,
donc nous ne nous sommes pas parlé pendant des années
, puis
et puis nous  tous les deux séparés des
femmes avec qui nous étions
et nous nous sommes retrouvés sans abri et nous avons donc
décidé d'
emménager dans un appartement ensemble dans l'ouest de
Londres nous avons eu beaucoup de fêtes nous avions
genre
30 30 30 ans nous avons eu beaucoup de
fêtes pendant un an
euh  fait des trucs fous que vous savez comme
vous le faites quand vous avez
30 ans. et puis nous avons créé des gorilles
pendant que nous vivions dans l'appartement donc
nous sommes très chanceux
et vous savez j'espère que ce seront
20 années incroyables à venir